'l'annonce va être bien reçu par un
grand nombre de femmes québec abandonne
le test pap le test de détection du
cancer du col de l'utérus pour le
remplacer par un autre plus efficace et
plus simple à réaliser le test vph c'est
très très très bonne décision parce que
c'est beaucoup moins être usirf le test
vph est un outil diène ne sait qu'on
utilise depuis longtemps pour détecter
le virus du papillome humain me virus
transmissible sexuellement qui est
responsable de 99 % des cancers du col
de l'utérus on l'utilisera maintenant
première ligne pour le dépistage
systématique de ce type de cancer le
fameux dépistage du vph hinault permet
justement d'avoir effacé lafarge
prélèvements
autour de ce nouvel outil québec mettra
sur pied un véritable programme de
dépistage organisé du cancer du col
le programme de dépistage viserait les
femmes de 25 à 65 ans on leur offrira de
passer un test tous les cinq ans pour
celle qui veut se faire tester mais qui
n'ont pas de médecin de famille il y
aura toujours le guichet d'accès unique
je pense que de passer par le guichet
d'accès va faciliter l'expérience
patients c'est ce qu'on veut pour les
hommes on évalue aussi la possibilité
d'offrir le test vph en mode d'auto
prélèvements à la maison avec un
écouvillon d'abord aux femmes en région
éloignée puis si ça fonctionne à toutes
celles qui le souhaiteraient différentes
stratégies
mais le même objectif
au canada une femme sur 168 développent
un cancer du col de l'utérus au cours de
sa vie il si normand grondin radio
canada montréal